hey 42 here how many friends do you have
if the answer is one or two or maybe
even not at all then you could be an
extraordinarily intelligent person
possibly even genius level even that's
or you're a massive gentleman's pickle
psychologist Satoshi Kanazawa of the
London School of Economics measured
their happiness levels of 15,000 people
with various IQ levels he measured the
happiness of all the subjects on two
occasions once whilst they were
socialising with a group of friends and
then again when they were completely
alone what the results showed was that
for people with low to average
intelligence levels you know those with
the combined brainpower of the Beckham's
reported greater self happiness when
they spent time with friends and it
seemed that the more friends they had
they're happier it made them but
astonishingly the exact opposite was
true for people with very high
intelligence levels they reported
greater happiness when alone in fact it
was noted that those at the top end of
the intelligence spectrum actually felt
considerably less happy when spending
time with friends some theorized this is
because intelligent individuals are more
skeptical of others they are more able
to see the faults inherent in human kind
and so prefer to not get tangled up in
the blues of their unpredictable and
unreliable brethren it's also false that
when intelligent people do form
friendships it's mostly for personal
gain or simply out of awkwardness and/or
expectancy whereas those mortals form
friendships for silly reasons like
emotional support or sometimes are lost
for attention and popularity smart
people don't need emotional support we
have our textbooks to create into this
aversion towards human interaction
actually intensifies in a predictable
and linear manner with increased
intelligence in the most prime examples
of mental acuity that we've come to know
and learn about in school we see a great
struggle to form bonds and relationships
with other beings the great Nikola Tesla
never married or
sex his tastes were far more avian in
nature he fell in love with a pigeon he
[ __ ] you nuts
he grew a great fondness for one
particular pigeon and actually wrote
this about her I loved that pigeon as a
man loves a woman and she loved me as
long as I had her there was a purpose to
my life that's a bit weird mate Bryan
may look alike and physicist Isaac
Newton was one of the most brilliant men
who ever walked the earth
seriously we owe a lot to him he founded
gravity calculus and the laws of motion
not to mention countless other things he
basically created the groundwork for all
modern day physics yet to say that he
was socially awkward is a gross
understatement
he was immensely private never formed
any kinds of friendships apart from a
mild acquaintance ship with a Swiss
mathematician and he died a virgin
happiness in intelligent people is the
rarest thing I know Ernest Hemingway and
he met a lot of people it's not that
highly intelligent people are antisocial
it's just that they are in the vast
minority of people and so struggle to
find others that share their views on
the world and accept them for all their
faults and they're often acutely
fastidious nature because after all no
matter how many times you've been told
the scientifically proven falsehood of
opposites attract it's actually
similarities that bring people together
and form lasting bonds and I guess
similarities we've always are scarce
when you are adamant that the Earth
revolves around the Sun and the rest of
the moronic folk that you share this
planet with put blankly refuse to
believe you
I know Copernicus it's tough but hang in
there mate they'll believe you
eventually just not in your lifetime but
Kanazawa study also found a disturbing
correlation that actually affects all of
us not just the geeks his findings shows
that people who lived in more densely
populated areas were significantly less
happy the
knows that live in less populated areas
this is not the first scientific study
to acknowledge this phenomenon countless
studies have found that big cities
Harbor hatred towards our fellow people
whereas the friendliest and most
inviting of people can be found in small
towns and rural settlements this
phenomenon has been observed all over
the world heck you don't even need
studies to observe this just try making
eye contact with literally anybody in
London or just being a person in Paris
people can be frosty at the best of
times even in these world-class cities
that supposedly provide everything a
person could ever want and more does
this then reveal a dark truth about the
human condition perhaps we're not
designed to live together with one
another no matter how intelligence or
unintelligent you may be now screw that
that's not true because studies show
that friendliness and compassion
actually thrive in very small
communities it actually goes back to
what evolutionary past our ancestors
living on the Great Plains of Africa
would have lived in small small groups
it was just more practical this way
easier to travel and safer when you know
everyone around you by grunts the only
downside to living in this way is that
you'd have to reproduce with your cousin
Oh aunt whichever you prefer really
groups rarely mixed and if they did it
will probably end up in conflict so
people stayed in their small communities
hundreds of miles from everyone else and
scientists believe that this same
attitude is still instilled deep within
us today as much as some people feel
like moving to a big city and forming an
enormous circle of friends will bring
them success and happiness and more
followers on instance
are just fighting against our own
evolution perhaps we should all just
learn to get along with the people that
we know first
unless you're highly intelligent of
course in which case I'm sorry but
you're just not cut out for
relationships maybe try befriending a
pigeon who knows it could even lead to
more thanks for watching do you ever get
the feeling that people are taught
thing about you behind your back well
that's because they are the British
government has what's called a division
of power in which the Prime Minister is
not at sea the country leader